الصندوق قد تم فتح ايضا
52 بالمئه
كان صوت
هو حصل على 26 مليون
[موسيقى]
مليون
وتسعه عشر والفارق بينهما باثنين مليون
و23
الفارق بينه وكذلك ان هناك نسبه التي لم
تدخل بعد
في المنظومه
وانه كان بنسبه
0.007 وحتى ولو كان كامل الاصوات لاحد
الطرفين لانه لن يؤثر على النتيجه
وبالتالي نرى بان الرئيس اردوغان قد تم
انتخابه رئيسا الجمهوريه مره اخرى
ونحن نتقدم بجزيل الشكر الى الناخبين
الذين هم شاركوا بحس سليم وان اننا نشكر
ايضا جميع اعضاء الهيئه العليا للانتخابات
وممثل الاح الذين هم عملوا ايضا في صنادق
الانتقاد والمنظمه المركزيه ايضا
لهيئتنا العليا كذلك كل من ساهم من
الوزارات وايضا المدراء
والمسؤولين وقوات الامن ايضا
ونحن نتقدم اليهم جميعا بالشكر وكذلك جميع
المؤسسات المشاركه ومن تابع وانتم
الاعلاميين خاصه الذين تابعتم كل هذه
المرحله الانتخابيه من البدايه واتمنى ان
تكون نتائج الانتخابات عائده بالخير على
الديمقراطيه التركيه وعلى الشعب التركي
واقول مبارك لكم النتائج
اذا مشاهدينا كنا نستمع الى رئيس اللجنه
العليا هذه الانتخابات الذي قال وفقا
للنتائج الاوليه فان الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان هو من فاز بهذه الانتخابات وطبعا
ذلك وفقا لان نتائج الاوليه